[Music]
Hello, I'm Adrian and it's been a little
while since I've done anything country
related. So today I thought I would talk
about chicken picking. Now what is
chicken picking? It is I suppose one of
the definitive country guitar techniques
and sounds. And uh at the risk of
stating the obvious, it's basically
making your guitar sound like a chicken.
And there are various ways that you can
achieve this, but it's usually done with
some kind of hybrid picking approach.
That is using a combination of notes
played with a pick and notes plucked
with one or two fingers of your picking
hand. and you mix together pick notes
and pluck notes and muted notes and you
get that characteristic clucking kind of
a sound. So I want to talk a little bit
generally about that technique and then
I'm going to take you through exactly
what I played at the start of this video
as well. So let's do it. So let me talk
about basic chicken picking technique to
start with. And the way I do it is this.
I'm alternating muted notes with notes
that I'm plucking with the middle finger
of my picking hand to get this kind of a
sound.
[Music]
So, so let's give this a try. Um, I'm
going to be playing on the G string
here. And I'm going to start with a
muted note that I'm playing with the
pick um of my picking hand. And and the
way I'm achieving that muted note is I'm
just resting the fingers of my fretting
hand lightly on that string just to
deaden it completely. And you get that
muted sound. Um, and then I'm following
that up with a note that I'm plucking
with the middle finger of my picking
hand. So, I'm playing the seventh fret
note here on the G string. Um, pressing
down now um on the note and I'm
just playing that with the middle finger
of my fretting hand. And I'm actually
snapping it quite
hard. Um, you get the string to snap
against the frets and that gives you
that plucking kind of a noise. So,
that's that's the basic idea. um a muted
note followed by the the plucked note.
So, and that that's the basic technique
that you're going to need to get
comfortable with to start with. And I I
suggest just playing some notes up and
down the length of of one string just to
get used to this technique. So, uh
um or you might want to try going up and
down a scale using that technique.
[Music]
So, let me take you through this little
solo that I've written which illustrates
how these techniques work in practice.
And uh I've designed this to work over a
very simple country chord progression.
And we're in the key of G and we've just
got
G going up to
C back to
G and
D
C and back to
G. So very simple 145 in the the key of
G. And you'll hear how each of the licks
I play um outlines those kind of
harmonies. So let's begin with the the
opening lick then which goes like like
this.
[Music]
Um so we're starting off with a slide up
to the ninth fret on the D string. And
then we've got the first of our plucked
notes which is the eighth fret on the B.
So, we've got a a pick note and then one
I'm plucking with the middle finger of
my my picking
hand. And then we have this series
of notes um along the length of of the G
string using exactly the technique that
I I was just uh describing to you. So,
we've got the muted note followed by the
the plucked note. So, um that the notes
we're playing on on the uh on the G are
just
10 9 7 and then 53. And we're just
preceding those notes with a with a
muted note. So we've
[Music]
got like So if I put all of that
together, we've got three,
[Music]
four, and uh then next little bit goes
like this.
[Music]
So, I've got a slide from one to two on
the A
string. I've got open
D, open G, and then I'm pulling off
here. Three to two to open on the D
string, and then two on the
A, open D, and then a low G note there,
third fret on the low E string.
again using a combination of pick and
fingers to play that. So I think it's
[Music]
pick finger there then
pick finger there and pick
finally. So all of that
[Music]
together all of that outlining nicely a
G kind of a a harmony. Um next phrase
goes like this.
[Music]
Um, so it's it's almost exactly the same
phrase that I've just uh transposed to
fit over the sound of a C chord. That
the first half of that is exactly the
same lick. So uh um I'm starting off
with a slide um up to the ninth fret on
the G and then plucking the eighth fret
on the high E string.
And this time I'm coming down the B
string with that muted note and the
pluck note. So it's going from the 11 10
8 and then sixth fret on the B, eighth
fret on the G. Um
um next little bit was
[Music]
this. So here I've got a slide from two
to four on the
G, plucking the third fret on the top
string. And I've got a a muted note. I'm
just playing the the the G string. I
think
muted, pulling off from five to three on
the B. And then four on the G and three
sliding up to eight on the B.
[Music]
So that's outlining the the C the C
chord to start
[Music]
with going back to
G. Then the harmony changing to D. And
I've got this
idea, just a series of of ascending
sixths. So 11 on the G, 10 on the high
E, and then I'm going up to 12 on the G
and the E, 13th fret, and 14th
fret. And here, I think I'm probably
using a bit of palm muting on the G
string to get that muted
sound. It's a kind of combination of
both left hand and right hand muting
here. Um, and then the next bit
[Music]
This is chords go back to to uh to C
again here.
Um sliding up to the ninth fret on the
G. And then I've got 8 10 11 12 on the
high E. And I'm sort of alternating
those notes with the uh with the mutes
notes. So,
[Music]
um, and then the final
phrase. Oops.
No. That's it. So, that that was
um sliding up to the 15th fret on the B
and then plucking the 15th fret on the
the high E, the high E.
really our same same phrase just
descending along the high E this time.
So we got 15 13 12 10
8 then playing 11th fret on the B maybe
giving that a slight push sharp as
[Music]
well. And the last little
bit that's just sliding up to the
seventh fret on the
G, plucking the sixth fret on the
B. And I've got a couple of muted notes
on the G
string. And then I've got the third fret
on the G going to the fifth fret on the
[Music]
D. So if I just put all of that together
for you quite slowly, it should sound
like this.
[Music]
So, I just want to finish by playing it
through a little bit faster along to the
chords which I've just put into my
looper pedal here. So,
[Music]
Well, that's it for now. I hope this
lesson helps you to get your chicken
picking chops together. Uh, if you've
enjoyed this lesson, do check out my
website where you'll find loads more
country lessons as well as lessons
across a whole range of other styles.
Thanks for watching and I'll see you
again soon. Bye-bye.